this is a production of cornell
university
that's right frank you know 14th episode
of the cornell turf show this week
in a cornell turf show first we're going
to have two guests today so we're
excited
um we'll have an annual bluegrass
vehicle conversation with dr
olga castromeister hopefully i'm i'm
getting that right olga
from umass and we'll get her perspective
on some abw movement this year
um but frank you can introduce our first
uh a guest
um board member gcsa ny and
a friend of yours joe lucas if you'd
like yeah well we'll get to joe we'll
get to joe
in a minute carl let me let me get to
the i gotta
say a couple of things i got to set joe
up and i want to give you a chance to do
your tip
uh because i want to give joe a chance
for people to trickle in or
pay attention because i'm sure it's
going to be a treat
welcome everyone uh and especially our
guests
and for those of you watching live uh
please think about some questions
certainly abw
questions but we'll talk about some
other things uh joe is here to highlight
a program that we're working on with the
gcsa and why
uh here in new york state but nice
picture of the winner from thad thompson
i will not use the expletively used by
my man that out there in western new
york but
those of you on twitter know it's
colorful and then a little picture of a
stow away here and stephen tucker
a leading equipment technician uh one of
his carts uh
a stowaway here a little baby owl and
you know you want to be careful they
look cute but you don't want to mess
with these guys
uh brian dagnu in in massachusetts
posted such a great picture i thought
um boasting hey how good everything
looks
and no inputs obviously he striped it up
got the mower going
but nothing else and it really leads in
nicely oh we're up
carl hold on a second so carl listen you
know what the conversation is
today with with uh olga and olga i'm not
going to make an attempt at your last
name but i'm going to
appreciate when we get when we get to
you you're going to tell me exactly how
to pronounce it
we're talking abw today and i'm going to
talk a little bit about your state park
stuff
but why don't you take a minute now and
talk about this
project with rit the erp project where
we're getting adoption of bmps
uh across western new york here central
and finger lakes
and we've got this wonderful infographic
poster that you can grab
uh at the website um and carl wanted to
highlight what the tip is of the week
today yeah so you know this can go for a
lot of different uh
diseases or insect pests but but it's
relevant to today's conversation on abw
but you know scouting i i know a lot of
people hear about scouting and
and that i think for a lot of people
just means kind of driving around and
looking at things but
you know we'll talk about today's
scouting especially for abw
and uh in high pressure areas you know a
lot of our long island golf courses
scouting is a real intentional data
gathering exercise to determine
not only timing of treatment but the
where you're going to treat so
you know a great resource for abw
scouting our
cornell soil ecologist kyle wickings has
created this pdf document for
management of annual bluegrass weevils
and he goes through and really
illustrates well the scouting techniques
if you're scouting for adults
early in the year as you can see on on
this side for our youtube audience
you know using some dish soap setting
out an area kind of pouring that on the
turf waiting a little bit
and then counting how many adults you
see kind of come up to the surface
as a result as a result of that soap
plush uh of vacuuming that you know
vacuuming is one thing kyle and
dr ben mcgraw and olga i'm sure you may
have played around with this but a
really easy way if you can set up
kind of one of these vacuum devices kyle
again goes through this in his pdf
document
pretty easy to set this thing up you
just vacuum and that's another
easy way to scout and then at the larval
stage again we'll talk about kind of all
these stages of abw today but
if you're gonna go out and make a
larvicide treatment uh the salt flushes
is the way to go there it's a little bit
tougher to see those the small
small guys in there but again all this
stuff is laid out in this
abw document and scouting really is
going to determine
when and where you're going to apply
insecticides especially for avw
all right carl thanks for that and i
want to get to our guest
joe lucas and joe before before i bring
you on
i want to just go through a little uh
presentation here
uh highlighting some things that uh some
of the funding that you guys are able to
generate will go to support and we have
you know a pretty elaborate uh center
here for
our golf turf research where we study
all kinds of things crazy things like
you know joe
when we ripped up that tea uh and tried
to get it planted back and
this kind of uh real progressive
research
um you know doing it on golf courses is
the kind of work
that we see the future of of turfgrass
research being
collaborating with you guys in the field
so that you can keep the areas up
and then we can do some of the research
on these golf courses of course
you know it costs uh funds to do these
things
uh we've gone around the region burning
things looking at
non-chemical approaches uh alternatives
to traditional herbicides
and course recently with carl's
leadership been doing
extensive work on understanding traffic
the science of traffic on golf courses
whether it's
you know the sophisticated work we do
with footwear design with foot joy
or it's cart traffic and nutrient use
we've also done a fair amount looking at
uh analyzing pesticide risk and carl and
michael beckham a colleague
and former grad student doug soldat and
myself just recently published this
paper
culminating from a lot of our work with
state park
research on golf courses helping our
industry and the public
understand pesticide use on golf course
is better
of course uh we've done the wash pad
stuff
as well all kinds of practical
environmental stewardship so joe
i've got a link here pal that i hope you
can still see my screen
takes us to the rounds for research page
that the gcsa maintains for us
and it looks like new york has about 81
participants and you can click on that
and find out
where all these things are so let me
stop sharon take a look at you
welcome you to the program give you a
chance to talk a little bit about the
rounds for research program
from a gcsa and why perspective
um the gcsa ny i believe this is our
second
full season as a new superintendent
organization
uh we were the western new york finger
lake central new york region
and we've combined into one association
and yeah i guess bigger is better maybe
in this aspect
and with the rounds for research
it's an opportunity to raise some really
good money um
in the old associations everybody got
little bits
and so no bigger pool bigger money and
we sat down and said
instead of trying to divide this out and
give it to everybody
a little bit we all said you know what
let's give it to you know cornell let's
give it to frank and carl
and let's really support our new york
turf
university let's keep the money in state
and really make a name
for new york and the groundbreaking
stuff and
you know everybody needs money and
anything that we can do
and can help promote better research you
know like
when we started doing that phrase moment
thing i think we just
start at the tip of the iceberg and i
know my owner
funded part of that you know i think we
wrote a check for like 2 500 bucks out
of
our own operating income and you know
what we should be doing that in the turf
industry
and people in the state who are bidding
on these rounds should know where that
money's going
and if we can partner with cornell
because cornell carries weight
that name in new york carries a lot of
weight to sit there and say
the money that we raise from this is
going to do this
yeah um yeah and yeah the more we really
the better we can i mean it's great for
a bunch of golf course superintendents
to get around and write some papers and
talk
and get an article in the local paper
but nothing stands out better than a phd
from cornell talking about
what we're doing in the state yeah i
mean yeah and that's exactly what we
hope the future holds for the
partnership and
i'm so glad to see the organization get
off the ground joe
and that you and the folks in the
leadership of that organization
you know getting the newsletter out
getting the website up and going we're
just uh
we're just getting started so appreciate
you taking the time to
join me and i can't wait to come back
out and see those teas
uh that i worked on all that time ago
all right all right thanks a lot joe
anytime all right so
so listen let me let me do a little bit
of weather carl
let me do a little bit of weather and
let me set up you a little bit olga
uh and then we'll get to our
conversation today um i just want to
remind everybody just in simple
broad terms you know overall the
northeastern united states remains
you know quite a bit ahead of normal
when you're looking at things that
determine how the spring is progressing
but you notice there's this big a
gradient in the middle of the country
where it's been uh pretty stalled for a
while
uh when you get south of us uh into the
southern new jersey mid-atlantic and
down into the carolinas
i know that doesn't necessarily apply to
everyone on the listening or watching
but for sure we're starting to see our
soil temperatures getting creeping into
the
mid to low mid to upper 50s
throughout the state except in the
higher elevations in some locations the
catskills and the adirondacks
but you really see the soil temperature
starting to come on and of course we
know
that's the beginning of really driving
things and getting them going so you got
to have water
well up to this point there's been a
good gradient there's been a
a generally a drier uh
period of time some drought areas that
are now benefiting from significant
rainfall
over the last couple of weeks but as we
heard this morning from our art from our
weather guy
rd guy tano here here in the uh
northeast climate center
that we're in for a little bit above
normal temperatures
and um above normal rainfall
for much of the region now there's going
to be a strong gradient if you look at
these maps
where the line of rainfall is is where
the big question mark is
if you look in the precipitation you say
it looks like it's right at the hudson
valley or southern connecticut there
and so we're not sure where that line's
going to be but it's going to be a stark
difference
between very warm uh and
dry and cooler and wet
and so we think to the northern part of
this line it's going to be fairly wet
art's talking about a
a couple of inches of of rainfall over
the next
couple of weeks for sure and what the
other thing
that i talked about was the um whole
idea that
uh that that the mins were gonna be
much above normal so the the daytime
temperatures themselves
uh may not be that warm uh the high
temperatures may not be that warm
but the minimum temperatures are going
to stay
uh fairly warm through the through the
um through the uh
nighttime hours so olga i want to give
you a little bit of a spiel
of some of the work that carl and i have
done uh
with the state park folks and carl's put
together the data here over the years
looking at the environmental impact
using the eiq
of our annual bluegrass weevil program
particularly at bethpage but really on
long island in general
we were able to associate about 57
of all the risks of pesticide use with
either annual bluegrass
or weevil or dollar spot now i want to
particularly talk about the work that
was done
looking at annual bluegrass weevil and
of course many years with jennifer grant
down there working on this as well now
ben and albrick did a survey a number of
years ago
looking at the number of applications
number of tees damaged and so here are
the
teas greens and fairway damage from that
survey that i'm sure you're
uh familiar with and then in our work
about 21
of the total risk of pesticide use on
long island golf courses that we
measured
were associated with annual uh bluegrass
weevil so
uh we instituted a really tight uh
scouting program we we looked
we took data and then we began to
target applications and of course we
were also on the black course in
particular dealing with pyrethroid
resistance so
over the years you could see we were
able to reduce the environmental risk
reduce the treated areas uh on on the
golf courses and
reduce the number of treatments that we
were making to abws we've been able to
choose
uh softer products over the years
and so obviously we hang this on
scouting better
right olga and choosing better materials
now recently
i saw this paper uh in golf course
management i haven't read
the scientific paper uh behind this and
and i'm
hoping you have some understanding of
this stuff because
here are the questions for today for for
you and me and carl and everybody that's
going to be watching or listening i want
to go through sort of where we're at
this year
because seems like phenology and data
might be
uh inconsistent but i want to cover that
with you
we're expecting warmer weather so i want
to hear about that and then
obviously we've lost chlorpyrifos so
that's going to create some
questions for our superintendents and
then the larvicide only strategy where
we abandon
adult applications and go to larvicide
so
thanks for taking the time uh to uh
join join us uh on the show and
welcome to the northeast and i wanted to
use this as a chance to invite you
and promote the things that you're doing
there umass uh
pretty big shoes uh to walk into right
with the great lady that preceded you
and i
of course we we expect the same things
uh great things from you so
welcome to the northeast and let's not
waste any time over
how are the abw's progressing through
the northeast right now
so what i see uh from our area and it's
very different this year because it's a
little bit confusing for me we much
closer for instance new england com and
new jersey in this region south region
much closer than any previous years
let's like in terms of the abw activity
which confused me in the beginning this
year so it's a little bit confusing
what i notice in terms of the weather we
didn't have this
stretch of the cold weather stretch of
the warm weather
we had this mosaic so you have couple of
days
really nice bright vehicles out there we
collect the vehicles
and we start seeing activity um
so first bubbles we start seeing in the
last week of
march so first vehicles on a
short grass it's really early like we
wouldn't expect
golf course superintendent alert me for
that we start collecting
we see vehicles and this was a little
bit something really alarming for me to
see them that early
then we start monitoring since late
march
and significant increase because this
mosaic weather
happened uh somewhere in the first week
of
april first second week of april we see
significant increase in numbers
and then they seems to be hanging out
there for until now
and so in the beginning i was like
really
almost like almost like trigger ready
right to like say what
we need to hurry up with everything but
at the same time um degree days wasn't
in place yet
at that time in like mid april and even
though we had these hot days and
everything but because of this mosaic
pattern what do i observe that uh for
syria was
late and it's still a little bit late
but i think it's because of drought
a little bit that's something for city i
was late and
um but at the end so in spite of this
mosaic a little bit the dispersed kind
of activity of vivos even though they've
been like
compared to the previous year 2020 it
seems to be much more clear
like they out there and they stay there
we don't have waves we don't have like
just at least what i observed from my
observation and i've been vacuum them
almost twice a week so that's what we
saw they see what they stay out there
i dissected the evil stew to look at the
reproduction they've been kind of
uh females were ready really like in the
mid of april i guess they were not
laying eggs probably because
they were not full of eggs they probably
were mating but they were ready
and by now they probably yeah
so thank you thank you for bringing up
the the
life cycle and the reproductive and the
feeding
because that appears to be what this new
research is suggesting
you know we we try to time these
adulticides
with peak adult emergence right you want
to get the most bang for your buck you
don't want to have to
like get it when it's 50 whatever your
count is and then
three days later it looks like you did
nothing there's a hundred more
and then you make another and you know
before you know it you're making those
five applications olga right
so we're trying to avoid that get the
peak emergence but it's almost like the
new
thinking is you guys are going towards
all right it's not just emergence
but how many eggs uh what's in their gut
what are they doing and somehow that's
going to refine our application strategy
can you talk about that a little bit
a little bit what i have i i've done
some dissection previous years and it's
like kind of with
like along the lines what in the paper
is too and i did
really significantly section this year
like all this season i've been
every sample we got because i was so
confused with this 22nd of march like
last week of march
first appearance of abw and i'm like
yeah i'm dissecting them to make sure
what i see there so and what i can say
that and another thing what we did we
did the two pitfall traps we did the
tall traps near where winter inside
and one of them near the fairway so to
make sure
what we don't have this waves right so
when we don't see any mobiles in the
over winter inside pitfall trap that
means they all gone and that's what we
see very clear this year
so they've been like huge move at least
from
location i had a huge move from them and
no more into the pitfall trap on over
winter insights they all kind of move in
one way almost like it's always it's for
biological it's never like all
black and white obviously so it was
variation but
so i started dissecting them uh they've
been
when from what i saw when they on the
short cut grass
they have like females ready right but
ready for reproduction doesn't mean
ready for the laying eggs they do have
fully developed they have food probably
they have a fully developed like
recovered
reproductive system because they go uh
so just
maybe for somebody who doesn't know when
they overwinter then
they only overwinter inside if you
dissect them
you see only fat that's it you don't see
digestive system too much it's really
clear
really transparent it's like nothing
like you can actually see really clearly
even if you do like
and same with a reproductive system
ovaries transparent translucent you
don't see it's really small
really tiny not only there no x present
you see like certain structures but it's
really in same males and females
you don't see them that much and when
they proceed in the season when they
start
feeding you start seeing this growing
right the
male reproductive system grow females
already become
like bigger and they become more sort of
like you know like creamy colored
because they absorb
all this yolk and like preparing for the
developing of the eggs
and then later on you start seeing this
ex fully develop
eggs but it doesn't mean what they're
ready to lay them yet so
they usually pack up that's sort of my
observation this year i have
obviously i need to support it with
research a little bit longer
but they usually pack about up to 14
eggs before they lay them so
it's a lot so if you see a couple of
them yeah so are you
suggesting now that we might adjust
our adulticide timings to coincide with
egg egg development in females
and target that adult population
not just adults in general but a
particular
type stage of adult females and that
dissect this is so great we're having a
conversation about weevil
gut dissection where do you get this
where else can you get this kind of
programming nevertheless
is that what you're saying olga that
that by doing this we're going to be
able to say let's target
the females right when they're full of
eggs before they lay them
so i want to bring a little bit
different perspective of that that's
right
so i dissected that to support
with our timing what we promote right
it's correct
and it seems like it is you know it's
like all of this this action
this year showed me yeah they might have
the eggs in the beginning when you just
see them right
but usu like usually they start mating
they have about two four eggs inside
right
so unless they pack with this eggs they
will not lay eggs
and it's for all the coincidence lucky
or not
it's exactly what we recommend you know
like it's about what 125 140
150 degree days uh for syria have green
have
golden so it's all kind of comes
together you know
we so we like the data and we like
phenological indicators equally
they are two good tools yes so i
like what i would suggest like i think
carl mentioned that
you do need to look at the degree days
pay attention to that
they might be not specifically 125 maybe
a little bit less
but somewhere in this region have to
look at the phenological
and scouting absolutely necessary tool
and you like again you don't be patient
that's what i'm like learned this year
absolutely because i'm kind of more
an action anxious side so be patient you
like look you see the first adults just
keep scouting until you see this
definite increase in this plateau when
they
kind of peek in don't forget some of
them might lay eggs but it's minimum of
them
you know like majority of them you will
target the correct time that's my right
all right so we we got to talk chemicals
now that's right this is this is the
deal
once we figure out we're gonna what
we're gonna do um
we just uh are going to see the end of
chlorpyrifos here in new york state olga
i'm sure you've heard that news and
i'm sure it's going to ripple into the
region in not much time
so what are you telling people that are
probably using chlorpyrifos because
pyrethroids didn't work so well
what are you telling the people in that
pickle that might not have stocked up on
the chlorpyriforce or just don't have
access to it
what are you telling those uh managers
over i've been
uh you know like uh i did my postdoc in
albrecht lab
so you imagine i'm from that school yeah
i am definitely like i did a lot of
research in the resistance
and obviously my view yeah larvas sides
it's more about the answer compared to
adulticides
for many many reasons number one what we
had pyrethroids and chlorophyll force
we're losing chlorophyll force in this
area too
so it's not only you so we don't have ap
anymore
with pyrethroids we have resistance
developing so it's like gun
and it's not only because we don't like
it
besides the fact that they brought
spectrum not great for ipm and all of
this
uh negative effect of the adult
adulticides what we talk about all the
time
plus even if you apply if you have
slightly resistant population
whereas nothing will happen you know
like you will still have to treat
larva no matter what and plus timing too
you know like so time and it's really
hard this two years with the
uh 2020 being cold season here
dude in this mosaic pattern this year i
think it's easy to get them 2020 but
it's
it's very uh narrow window and it's
really hard to get good timing with
adults
right and so that leads us to the larvae
question right which i got to ask your
colleague dr wicking
this morning when we wake up at 7 30 for
that ridiculous conference call that
i've been doing
for 20 years um and kyle mentioned
that um you know this is tricky uh this
is i
i basically couched it by saying it's a
risk i mean these things are in there
and you're hoping you got to get the
timing right we're having a tough time
with these
uh adulticide timings but you seem to
sound like maybe we've got better
efficacy with larvicides
and it may be a better handle on timing
but we still gotta scout pretty closely
absolutely we still keep scouting for
adults because this will be a ground
zero to count when the timing for larva
sides right
so and for larva sides you have several
options to work with right
you have this uh early larvacides what
we talked about when i was in rutgers
basically what its target that larva
would still feed inside
and you need to imagine that but you
cannot get it with contacts you need to
go with systemics here and then we have
on chenille
diamines unfortunately neonicotinoids
don't work really well for vivo so
like it's for now we left for
ontranillic diamites for this stage
but this could be applied as early as a
position in the first and star
and this is kind of like negotiation
between the
adult sides preventing still preventive
right you don't see the damage yet too
much
and kind of between the larva sides and
then the second option for larvacides
and you have much more chemical classes
for that
it's when they start coming out of the
plants it's about we will target maybe
2.53
in star and average rate and we will in
its
indoxacarb goes match point spinozad
and fern still works at this time so we
have more
variety in terms of the rotating
chemical classes
within the resistance so you can go with
either one
and i think honestly i'm not sure but i
feel like uh
catching at least with my application my
research it's easier to catch time with
the
larvae sides when with adult decides
okay so listen we're we're at the
witching hour here
and i i wanna you know i got crane fly
questions i got a beautiful picture from
greg stanley out on the east end of long
island
okay with a crane fly on his hand but
we're not going to do that
because because i want to ask you a more
important question about abw
stuff which is okay we go larvicides we
change the adult size we change the way
we do things and the last time i checked
from talking to smart people like
albrecht and ben and kyle
and you and other people who are looking
at these things
and they're saying yeah but we don't
really know what to do with the second
generation
yes third generation so even if i get
this one
i still got a little bit more let's just
start with the simple question
how does anything we might miss now
affect what you're thinking might be a
second or third generation
so yeah that's a hard loaded question i
would say
yeah some it's really hard to catch and
uh
what i'm thinking like you know like
we're all saying you need to get the
first like this over winter and for many
reasons you put your effort on that you
will have less trouble later
if you still have it i think we still
going with the larvae side that's what i
i know that's most effective and as soon
as you start you still monetary adults
and coming from the adults i see you see
adults on that and like
target your larvae side application in
during the summer you know like and you
decide what you're going with and i know
people do different combination in terms
of
mostly between the diamines and spinoza
at that point
but you you open for the inductor carp
and even
some spot treatment for curative
application people do different things
like dialogues and but
we want to avoid this one yeah yeah and
the bottom line is olgo everything i
hear you guys telling me is
chemicals are only really only a part of
the solution here
if you don't target these things right
we're not going to have a lot of
materials left
because you can imagine you know you
start freaking out about larvicides and
now you're making three or four of those
a year
and now you've got multiple resistance
yes um
so listen i want to thank you for
joining us
uh call their questions
i i would i would love now olga can you
pronounce your last name for me properly
castramitsca costramitska
perfect appreciate that olga okay carl
thank you for joining us olga a big
shout out to joe and the gcseny
the auction is open so go there and uh
you know we wish we had more of our big
guns on there
like my boy jeff corcoran get a nice
little foursome at oak hill
uh i'd like to press him for that so
there's my shout out joe
to start twisting arms uh here carl get
us out of here
yep uh thanks olga again and today's
conversation i can hear joe snickering
in the background because he's got an
all bent grass course and he's
he's letting those uh abw take out his
pillow really
willingly um so i and of course thanks
to joe and gcsa and why
for their support of our research
program frank as you talked about
we're very system-based we like to do
this on golf courses that's very
practical-minded and resonates a lot
with uh with superintendents around here
so
um with that we'll get everybody out of
here tomorrow we're going to have sean
peyster a director of longwood gardens
on to talk about some of his
sustainability initiatives that'll be a
fun one but
until then uh we'll see you all later
thank you thanks olga
thanks joe appreciate it you guys
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu